so obviously my initial ban was was four
years I then received the further
three-year ban
coaching athletes that compete so that
told my ban to seven years weightlifting
has been biggest part of my life ever
since I was 11 years old and have that
taken away from you it's very difficult
I suppose it's I can only liken it to if
there's anyone listening is probably
losing a loved one or something very
similar because it made up so much of my
life and still does as heartbreaking as
that was and it was a very low point in
my life after that I had to draw a line
in the sand if I was ever gonna be able
to move on with my life
I learned this you've really got a
burning desire to achieve and I never
did what I do now to prove anything to
anyone else I've got my own goals and my
own Drive and you never want to lose
sight of the fact that it is your own
journey and they're your obstacles
ladies and gentlemen welcome back a most
to get him all the way from the other
side of the planet it's sunny Webster
are you mate hey Chris Aiden brother
yeah good to see man how's how's life in
the future cuz you're in the future
right now a lot being funny mate this is
a long overdue chat I can't when was the
last time I was on the podcast over a
year ago now so it was that same weekend
that we did was it the same weekend we
did L row coincidentally the the last
time that I drank in the UK so it's been
like eight yeah man that was that was
the last time that I drank in the UK so
it'll be like what 14 months or
something now since then I'm not saying
that going out with you that curse
drinking
you are like before we even start
talking about anything can we discuss
about your ability to drink because I've
never met anyone who is able to go out
like on the on the lash the way you are
and then get up the next morning and
just go and do it teach a seminar in
Scotland or something you got to put
like 10 a.m. or 11 a.m. I didn't I
didn't surface until like the middle of
the afternoon by the time that I'd got
out of bed you've done a seminar in
Glasgow or something do you know what I
think it's part of like their growing up
is you have to be able to drink you will
never become a great weight lifter if
you can't drink I remember right back
from a young age I must have been 14
years old going on weightlifting
training camps and the more senior
athletes would say to write on a Friday
night after training you're coming to
the pub with us and you're having a
drink
and you don't really have a choice you
do as you're told because they're much
bigger much stronger than you and you
want to fit in and it becomes part of I
guess the nature of you know being a
weightlifter especially the way that we
go about you know competition you would
train really hard for like six weeks
seven weeks maybe up to six months on
end for a competition and you won't
drink at all so then you blow out
your ability binge drinking becomes
extremely good yeah it's definitely
something that you're capable of I
suppose as well like weightlifters a
there's a lot of muscle mass in there
they can probably metabolize their
alcohol pretty quick and the foot that
competitive you're literally bred to be
competitive so competitive drinking I
can imagine is pretty bad but what else
is going on man cuz like so the last
time that the listeners would have seen
you you were in the UK you were yeah I
don't think it even started like there's
Sonya Webster Academy by then so like
catches up over the last year what's not
yeah well I guess before I saw you enter
last year I was just sort of planning my
tour to Australia I mean I was
definitely going through a period at the
time after we last chatted of not
feeling completely settled in the UK it
took me a long time to really realize
that because I was continually going on
these trips to Doha going on these trips
to Europe to do seminars and as much as
I was enjoying traveling every time I
came back the next seminar seemed to act
almost as an excuse and I'd actually
left the UK that I began to realize that
I guess I don't know if it was more for
me wanting to you know spread my wings
and experience a new new country as a
kind of a sign there for me but
obviously I went away then on the big
Australia tour and it was life-changing
you know I fell in love with the place
I fell in love a beautiful lady and it
was only fitting then that I moved away
there then in January so towards the end
of my tour when I met my new girlfriend
Linda we decided to go to Bali for
Christmas together and we had the most
amazing time Christmas in New Year and
then it was like she lives in Sydney I
live in England if we're going to have a
go at making this work one of us has to
budge and she sure as hell wasn't Miss
Iranian
it was quite an easy decision which
which end of the world we was gonna head
up in but I mean I'd obviously just
bought my place in Bristol which I've
still got but it's amazing when you
really want to be somewhere else that
bad how quickly you can make the change
and I think that so many people are
scared and fearful of change or
something new but I'm kid you not I
lived in Bristol for seven years and I
managed to pack up my whole life in
seven days and moved as well I mean you
are quite well well experienced at
packing things up I've seen you again in
Bristol I've seen you pack pack up or
after a night out with me to go and do
like all the way you were going maybe my
bedroom here abathur or something like
that yeah you move pretty quick it was
all that you had in your suitcase was
like two pairs of lifters a pair of
off-white sliders and some shorts and
that was it I'll just get I'll get the
rest when I'm there but no yeah you're
right one thing that people might not
know is you've actually got a Aussie
passport right or you've got all these
citizenship New Zealand passport is that
it yeah a New Zealand one which kind of
works the same here it's kind of about
having a you know an Irish passport I
guess so I'm gonna stay here in
Australia on that visa but you know what
as a mentor because I'm still traveling
so much I could come and go on my travel
visa minoan even though really all the
excuses that people have where they
might think oh I don't really understand
how the the visas work or I don't have
citizenship in the same way that Sony
does or whatever if there's a will
that's sort of a way a lot of the time
yeah I know I know so many people living
here in Sydney from back in back in the
UK that have either come here and been
sponsored getting jobs or than the
farming it's not easy but like anything
if you really want to make it happen you
have the you could work and what's James
and Duran doing are they doing the
farming I can imagine I can see those
two on a farm
no so Darren Darren actually had a de
facto from a previous relationship that
he was here he was with someone for
seven years from Australia so he was
here a long time ago
I wish the next partner of his and then
James I'll see his business is based
this was a business visa so he can stay
here on on those those times read I get
the avoiding bastards
there's just sneaking around leaving the
UK leaving the rain behind and going out
somewhere cool those boys that yeah they
run on a different time clock to me
those boys are in bed at like 9:00 and
they're in the cafe at 6:00 which you
know I'm like moreover upper 7:00 and
work till like midnight but it does as
soon as you wake up in the morning then
you feel like you on the back foot and
you've got FOMA already and it's only
like 7 o'clock because they're already
done like any much she actually work in
the same field yeah James his 20
Instagram stories deep and he's already
done his email for the week and all that
[ __ ] and then there's you still
trying to drag your coffee oh it's yeah
pin in your eyes over there yeah so
what's been going on recently other than
obviously you've got yourself out
towards you've managed to find a
girlfriend now moved in with Linda as
well right yeah Linda is her birthday
this weekend so yeah she's there she
she's watching her programming that in
the in their bedroom but yeah for me I
think initially it took me a while to
get settled find my routine here
obviously I just launched the Sonny
Webster Academy which has been amazing
it's been great to be able to help more
people that was the key thing with the
Academy was that whenever I'm doing
these seminars I'd have to travel
halfway around the world and I'll be
able to impact 30 people's lives on that
given day and yes I know they'll become
aware for pibil and I have a great
experience but I wanted to be able to
offer that to a wider audience and
something that meant that I didn't have
to travel so much because it was taking
so much away from as much as I loved
traveling away from my time and my
endeavors and enjoyment in my own
training you know cuz it's
massively affected every time you travel
away every time you spend time in the
air you spool out your sink in your
routine and before you know I'm not
improving and I still love my lifting so
had with the Academy find a way of
accessing more people without having to
move so much and I've learned so much in
a year I can't believe that you know it
was only a year ago pretty much to this
day that I launched the sunny Webster
Academy properly and already we've had
thousands of customers and we've got you
know a lot of customers online now that
are on the subscription that I'm able to
work with which has been you know it's
been great and I've been learning so
much more about what people want and how
to work with people over the Internet
and it kind of is is the future now
really hmm
it's interesting that it's something
both like kind of selfish for your own
gains but selfless as well because it
allows you to scale you are right like
we were we were talking about this with
regards to my business which is Club
promo right like if I have to be the
person that stood on the door there's
only ever one of me
I can't scale the business beyond maybe
at best like one night per week like
every night of the week inside that's so
much graft but you're totally right
we've got our first online course which
is in beta testing at the moment which
is going super well and I've been able
to distill down the same way you have a
lot of things that I've spoken to people
about face to face and then you've
condensed it down into a format that is
convenient for people and they can deal
with it that way and you know like like
you say it's nice that you've got this
opportunity to reach to reach a wider
audience whilst not sacrificing the
results that people are getting on the
back end so yeah and and just and
yourself your own your own health but
it's it's so much harder than people
think it is like I can't stress that
enough like you think being online coach
is easy it's no problem you get a
membership site and off you go it's
really not that easy
what's the challenges what are the
challenges that you fund particularly I
think maintaining a high level of
service for the people that you work
with keeping up to date with people in
the
time zones you know it's been a massive
thing for me like it's easy if everyone
wakes up at 7:00 and everyone goes to
bed it at 10:00 and you know if you
schedule you're alive at nine o'clock to
interact with everyone as a whole
everyone's gonna be up right now we've
got people from all different parts of
the world on the academy it's very
difficult to sync with them all so
different standards of people and people
require different levels of coaching and
when you offer an online platform you
kind of speak one language okay it's
your people initially anyway because you
have the the program but then it's
realized like well you don't like it and
sworn to when when I'm teaching you how
to live but some people like that
encouragement and it's kind of tailoring
your service to the masses of people and
you need to have different levels and
it's taken me ages and months and months
and months of tailoring and refining the
programs and products that we've got
online to appeal to everyone and you're
never gonna keep everyone happy but
that's definitely one of the biggest
challenges I've found and then retaining
yeah I suppose that the issue there is
you need to have a you need to have a
program which is sufficiently similar
that it doesn't require you to write
every person's program absolutely
individually every single day plus do a
20-minute phone call with them because
you couldn't reach enough people but
then you also need to balance that with
a level of personalization which ensures
that the the language that you're using
the sort of communication like you've
said there's something I told you didn't
even think about time zones and ensuring
that people have got access at the right
times and stuff like that
so one thing that you've touched on
there is your own lifting your own
training at the moment obviously the
last time that we spoke I think you
would have probably still classed
yourself primarily as an athlete what
what do you see ourself as now do you
see yourself as athletes or as a coach
has there been a transition there yeah I
definitely still love you know the
competitive side of training myself so I
mean I'm still in the gym five six days
a week focusing on my own training but
it's very different now
I ain't aim for doing maybe one or two
exercises a day and doing it really well
and doing my mixture of CrossFit and
weightlifting and then yeah I'd say I'm
definitely I've been coaching now for
seven years so I've been in that coach
athlete role for a while now but I'm
definitely putting more emphasis I'd say
60/40 between coaching at the moment
than I am on on mathlete side of things
how have you found relinquish in that
thread attached to the balloon because
obviously no matter how much you love
coaching there is a particular type of
itch that needs to be scratched by
competition and you're right now you're
unable to do that yeah well I mean that
was you know a heartbreak in stage in in
my life and as you would have listened
to to James's podcast it was the first
time that I'd actually last year felt in
the right place to discuss my doping ban
and you know how it's affected me moving
forward you know weightlifting has been
biggest part of my life ever since I was
11 years old and have that taken away
from you it's very difficult I suppose
it's I can only liken it to if there's
anyone listening is probably losing
losing a loved one or something very
similar because it made up so much of my
life and still does and yes it is like
an itch now for me when you know I still
have that burning desire to want to
compete and to be competitive and it's
something you know that I can't do now
yeah you know having been around you for
quite a while and haven't been mates
with youth quite a while it's one thing
that I do think is impressive is your
resilience over the last sort of 18
months there's been a number of setbacks
like the first your first ban and then
like a subsequent kind of additional
like kicking the balls after that as
well and and that appears to be
continuing not just with competition but
with like coaching as well yeah I mean
obviously my initial band was was four
years
I then received the further three-year
ban coaching athletes that compete was
what they gave me the second band for so
that told my ban to seven years and even
so now I mean right back to when I first
came to Australia Australian
weightlifting Federation New Zealand
weightlifting Federation we're putting
in the news and stuff like that and say
if anyone attends
Sony's weightlifting seminars who's a
competitive athlete then you're impeding
a doping violation and therefore you
could get banned as well and it's been
the first time that they've ever tried
to impact these sort of levels of rules
on anyone and you know for myself
serving currently a seven-year ban one
of the longest bans it in weightlifting
especially for and out of hours our
competition test in which you know I
pursued my case and gave it a bloody
good go at proving that it come from
contamination and wasn't ingested
knowingly and I did everything I
possibly could to attempt to prove that
and still to come away with that level
of area ban was you know it was
heartbreaking but you know it's like I
said back on James's podcast as
heartbreaking as that was and it was a
very low point in my life after that I
had to draw a line in the sand if I was
ever gonna be able to move on with my
life and go yeah this is the most
terrible thing that could have happened
to you and at this point I'd only had
the four years but I need to continue on
with my life I need to continue to
spread my passion and love for the sport
and you know who's to say that I would
never have come back and competed again
but after having spoken out about that
last time was when I received this the
second three years so do you think
you're gonna do you think that you would
have got that or do you think that
speaking out and perhaps publicizing
what happened on James's podcast led to
that additional three years at least
hastening its arrival or like improving
the likelihood of it happening
a hundred percent you know there was
nothing that was brought up about it
prior to that but I think you know
having spoken out about the topic in
such detail with James it definitely was
put in front of you know the people
probably within you CAD and you know I
definitely think it stimulated that
three year ban going going into action
you know and I spoke quite brutally
about you know the circumstances that
there are now in the way that you can
deal with cases such as Tyson Fury's
where threatened to sue then he was
called an anabolic steroid
he threatened to sue them he's got more
money than you CAD and they let them off
with it you know and it does become a
point of if you've got enough money or
you're protected by the right people you
don't reap the same same I guess
judgment yeah yeah you don't yeah
without going into too much detail and
yeah I do believe that had something to
do with the three years it continued
that was just a further kick in the nuts
I mean I had thought about like I said
potentially coming back to competing
because you know I'm I'm aware that I'd
motivate an inspire a lot of people and
I want to continue to do that and I
think through competition that was you
know a massive motivation for people to
see how you know I perform and what I do
on the back end that was definitely
something that was different between
what I did as a weightlifter compared to
a lot of other weight lifters that I did
share my training my bad days my good
days and tried to always give that to
people as a lesson to learn from you
know what I do when I have a [ __ ]
training session and that's the thing
there's no different whether you're an
elite level athlete or you're just
starting your journey and fitness is you
both have bad days you'll continue to
have those bad days you'll have days
where you miss lifts you'll have days
where you don't feel like training it's
still the same either either end of the
scale that you're at and I think there's
a lot to learn from experienced athletes
in the way they deal that so it makes
learning curve for new people much
smoother yeah again coming back to the
resilience thing I have to say man like
I'm even from the first time that we met
each other which was body power last
year I've always been quite impressed
with your resilience and that's
resilience like it's kind of a blanket
coverage of resilience right so it's
your resilience to hangovers your
resilience to setbacks and other bits
and pieces professionally personally in
terms of your sporting careers stuff
like that because one of the first
conversations that we ever had when we
were at body power you'd had quite some
victory or comments by some other people
in the weightlifting community I don't I
don't know whether they were like um
officials or more like athletes or
whatever but there were some people that
were unhappy where they were they were
friends while they were even worse after
that but yeah like we had these sorts of
comments with people and what you said
this thing to me and it really stuck
with me and it still does now which was
the after you'd had your ban people
weren't prepared with just destroying
your sporting career they wanted to be
able to destroy your ability to make
money or to have a livelihood as well
I'm not really [ __ ] hit home to me and
outside cheese's like this this guy like
you know is is now trying to splinter
off into whatever small sliver of
weightlifting he can still involve
himself in you know with a high quality
of coaching that people obviously
resonate with with a style of social
media that is obviously engaging and
entertains people and it's like there's
people from within the industry within
the sport and then also bureaucratically
at the top of the sport that kind of
really trying to play whack-a-mole with
all of the different routes that you've
got to go out yeah it was I mean it was
difficult and when it comes to things
like that Chris like I said and I
learned my lesson when I went through
that period after my band you know there
will always be obstacles and I overcame
so many obstacles throughout my career
as a lifter
I learned that if you've really got a
burning desire to achieve and I never
did what I do now to prove anything to
anyone else I've got my own goals and my
own Drive and you never want to lose
sight of the fact that it is your own
journey and they're your obstacles and
whenever there was another one put in
front of me I found another way around
it and you do have to have that certain
element and resilience because you know
you could take 4 different routes and
get told no every single time and yes
it's [ __ ] heartbreaking
it hurts every single time but the
quicker and the better you get at taking
the emotional side out of how that makes
you feel and going but I'm angry I'm
frustrated what's been said I'm annoyed
at the result of that and going right
what have I learned from that how can I
change what's the next route and the
quicker that happens the better your
resilience gets and it happens in every
day stuff you get a parking ticket
you go and see that the kind of [ __ ] and
you get angry and you can let that ruin
your whole day you can have your whole
day stewing on the fact that you've got
paid 60 pounds and you won't pay it
because you're so frustrated and you'll
let it go two weeks and then all of a
sudden that 60 pound fines now 120 pound
fine we've all done it and it's through
bitter frustration that stops us moving
forward and ultimately ends up in us in
a worse place than where we were to
begin with you know at that point you've
got a parking ticket if you put your two
pound on the ticket okay it would have
taken you you would add to what the 15
minutes down the road to get the ticket
to come back you would have potentially
avoided that 60 pound fine that is your
lesson that you learn so by paying
ringing up paying that parking ticket
straight away and moving on with your
day lesson learned be able to achieve so
much more the rest that day and that is
a simple I guess analogy of the way that
I would approach being resilient
resilient to any sort of negativity that
I've had to deal with it's as simple as
that there's a really good quote from
Sam Harris where he talks about
try and remain angry for more than five
seconds without thinking about the fact
that you're angry and it's like the
actual fleeting sensation of emotions
they're so short-lived but the reason
that we hold on to them and this is
where a lot of the complications come
from is that it's very rarely about the
actual emotion it's about all of our
thoughts and our responses to whatever
that particular emotion is so if you
forget the situation forget the fact
that you got the parking ticket it's no
longer about the parking ticket it's
about how you ruminate over the fact
that you could have just walked out 50
meters or you should have just done this
oh you should have done that and this
happened it's internal
yeah it is a new perpetuator which and
then you become the after that you get
the second-order and third-order effects
which are where you become angry at
yourself for perpetuating the thing that
you didn't do in the first place and
it's so it's so delicious like it really
is there's there's a man's search for
meaning by Viktor Frankl anyone who's
listening and needs an easy read what
easy read it's about the concentration
camps in Nazi Germany but it is an
interesting read and this guy was a
psychologist psychotherapist who was a
Jew was captured second of the
concentration camps and his synopsis to
the entire book is that the final thing
that people can take from you which they
can never take from you the thing which
can never be taken from you is your
ability to choose your response to any
given situation and no one can ever ever
take that away from you and you think of
every situation that this guy's been in
he's been stripped from his families
watched his wife and child die in front
of him he's had all of these horrific
experiences but the final thing that
concentration camp guards couldn't take
away from him was his ability to respond
how he chose to any given situation but
that's it Chris in it it frustrates
other people further in the way that you
respond I mean it still you know for me
in in it on a daily basis the way that I
deal with making a stupid mistake I do
stupid stuff all the time I lose
my keys I lose tickets into car parks
and I deal with it and I and I pay the
fee out and final ever and I move on and
it frustrates Linda how can you you know
continually do those stupid things and
it not frustrate you and it's the same
with how can you get around you know not
being able to do a seminar but yet
you'll still go on and do the next one
what do we do next it frustrates people
in the way that you respond to your own
your own issues and it's not necessarily
I think a bad thing I think it's just
people deal with negativity positivity
any sort of emotion very differently and
it's hard when you know two people don't
respond to the in the same way yeah
you're right I think this probably
strikes at the heart of one of the one
of the reasons why some of the weight
lifters might be trying to make you out
to be more of a bad guy than you are
because they're projecting their own
inadequacies the fact that you have had
all of these barriers put in front of
you and yet you've still got a
flourishing online business you're still
selling out seminars it's like that I
think it is it that Chris Brown song
where the intro to it goes I don't see
how you can hate from outside of the
club you can't even get in it's like if
you sell five spots to a weightlifting
seminar how can you hate on the person
that's selling out thirty even with all
of these berries in place it's like
don't but don't try and make your own
performance better by bring some
bringing somebody else's down it's like
get on their level but this happens so
much in life in in the fitness industry
instead of people working together and
growing together and helping each other
cross-pollination it doesn't people
don't like seeing other people do well
and one thing that I've always done is
never put fuel on the fire you know I
get negative stuff I have to deal with
every single day and the people that
probably have to deal with it the most
is the people closest to me the people
that around me when I'm at my vote most
vulnerable the people that will see me
like Linda will see me at night when I'm
down depressed about something you know
they're the people that ultimately are
the ones that see you brunt the sort of
I guess when you're angry or when you
were depressed because I will never
project negativity across my social
media which is what people want you to
do but at the end of the day I do not
use my social media platforms to be
negative to talk about negativity it is
a place to promote positivity and
inspire and motivate people so you tend
you tend upsetting a lot of people
because they don't get that keyboard war
that reaction that they're always
looking for yeah you're right there's a
thinking about a podcast i did with
george mcgill which was mental models
101 and in that he talks about what he
thinks is the the single greatest or the
single most valuable characteristic of
the 21st century because it high agency
and the perfect way to think about who
your high agency friends are is to do
this thought experiment so imagine that
you're trapped in jail and you've got
seven days to get out and you have to
ring a friend like who is the friend
that you're going to ring like that
friend is the person who's got high
agency and people who have the agency
you see them you see them on the
internet we all know who they are right
like james has got high agency Darren's
got high agency you've got guys like Ben
and Lucy from my coach school that these
people who don't give a [ __ ] like don't
conform to whatever is expected of them
decide that they're just going to go
down the wrong way like cam cams got
high agency as well the guy that does
your stuff on the back end like he just
thought like bollocks for I'm just gonna
jump on a flight I'll go barley I'll go
here I'll do some content I'll do this
and yeah that that high agency approach
is exactly why it allows people to make
progress that others think is almost
unbelievable whether it be
professionally personally emotionally
you know in terms of their sport or
whatever it might be yeah that that I
love that that thought experiment who'd
you reckon you'd call if you needed to
get get yourself out of jail who would
you ring
[Laughter]
I could Jeff like with problems all the
time because he is one of the smartest
blokes I know he is one of the best he
is a extremely resilient human and he is
he never takes no as an answer and
that's why I know whenever there's a
problem that I can't solve I've put it
in front of him and he will it's a
challenge for him it's a challenge for
him to get that computer say yes and
he's extremely good at it and that is
you know but but as you know a huge
inspiration and motivation for me
because that is the way it attacks
everything and I guarantee that has a
massive contribution to why so
successful in learning in life but in
you know his business in a career he's
got as well yeah hi Agency money Jeff
Jeff - hi agency guy although some of
his shirts are like super hi agency I
Jeff if you listening man I'm watching
you on Instagram and some of those
shirts are outrageous well he's just
recently sent me I think yes they sent
me some cloth fabric from Dolce Gabanna
which is shades of purple to match up
specific paint-grade that Lamborghini
are doing on their new Lamborghini I
mean why not why not Jeff just do its
that's how I roll that is how he's not
worried about he just wants a new
see-through Louis Vuitton handbag that's
like perspex or whatever that crazy
thing that we saw you in last so yeah I
totally get it man I think as well what
you're talking about this kind of
unfaltering positivity you do show your
vulnerability online that we all do
right but I think you're right it really
really grinds on people when they don't
get the response that they wanted and
that response could be
something direct from you or the failing
of your career or the the even just the
slowing of your career right like when I
met you I think that weekend at body
power was when you cross 100k on insta
and what you are now like 250 or
something 220 yeah like so that you know
that's more than doubled in a space of
just over a year which is you know just
but I mean even even then quit sight
that has slowed that has slowed you know
and you know everyone's noticed it at
the moment and the way that Instagram
algorithms are working it's not how it
was I was at a period where I was making
maybe two thousand four hours a week so
now it's more like 250 followers a week
you know and it's a constant battle but
it does play with your you through
psychology a little bit but you put so
much effort and time into content and if
it doesn't get the right reaction or
likes or things that your engagement
that your you're looking for it has an
effect on you and it's mad you know how
Instagram have been playing around with
the likes I think to combat really
people's worry about what like so much
and just post more about what you're
passionate about and want to express but
yeah I mean it's one thing I've noticed
from all the guys that you know I'm
inspired by and in the industry in it on
a business level is consistency and if
something doesn't work the first time
don't worry don't give up keep on going
it keep on doing it being original and
keep doing your own thing after we got
off the cool today I'm gonna do my neck
school of sunny thing to post up it's
probably some of the worst engaged
content that I've put online in terms of
how many likes and views it gets but yet
it's probably the most valuable in terms
of why offer people in the videos but
it's five minutes long people don't want
to sit there for that long isn't it
interesting you have two isn't
interesting that we use and this is that
everyone knows this right everyone's
seen this before they've they've taken
ages crafting some beautiful photo and a
caption that's really meaningful to them
about
moment in their life and they've put it
on social media or if you're a content
creator maybe you've spent absolutely
ages crafting a really difficult video
so I got Joe Delaney shred Bundy
recently randomly did a video that was
like how to do a food shop from Aldi for
three pounds a day and this video
banged so hard like 1 million views in
the space of a couple of weeks and this
guy's worked on his YouTube channel for
probably about ten years and he's got to
100k subs right then in the space
another month he's done 50k and you just
think like what is it about this and it
is this total random almost random
lottery chance of winners and losers and
you're right I do wonders moving forward
for social media if they were to get rid
of the likes whether that would signal
people to post content which would be
more valuable we've all seen it right
you take ages doing this thing put this
really beautiful photo and you go ah
that didn't go so well then you post
like a random funny thing if you've
fallen over in a pool or a view like
looking semi lean with a bit of a tan
and bang it goes crazy like there was
that one there was that one that you've
done that was like I think it's just a
close feet clean grip snatch on a put on
a red plate back in bristl and play and
it did that quarter of a million views
and then there's some things where
you've nearly taken your own head off
and it's like nothing it's it's a
combination of lighting timing you know
that everything that you know people
people looking for in a video but it's
like tick-tock I don't know if you had a
play around with it yeah no no I am it's
then it's the new sort of I guess
Instagram it used to be musically oh
yeah I know those chap is shouting about
it because it's kind of like the next
platform and so I'm playing around on it
at the moment just more than anything to
be ahead of the curve see what people
like what people don't like but it's a
very young audience on there and
lindell's done a video on there recently
and she got three point six million
views on it and all it is is man
stood looking fat but holiday blow and
then turning around and then like I'm
tensing and she's like doing a model
pose 3.6 million views she's now like
twenty five thousand of thirty thousand
followers on tick-tock overnight through
but it's crazy I would like the same so
I get this as well right like some of
the some of the times when I'm posting
of content and it's different for me
because this podcasts a passion project
although you know increasingly it's but
it's growing I looked on the channel
today they do you like on YouTube that
ten thousand subscribe
yeah they had probably one one when I
was on it yeah I think I think when you
came on we were probably on about two
and a half and yeah like it is we
crossed a million downloads the other
week we've just hit 10k subs are about
two million views on YouTube so yeah but
one of the problems is and everyone will
know this right with regards to their
life generally and social media is like
a very concentrated form of what we
broadcast out in our lives in any case
it's a reflection of real life anyway
people sometimes do things that they
know will receive social reinforcement
and will make them feel good because
other people will make it'll be on the
surface level quite viscerally
satisfying but might not actually be the
most meaningful or the most value adding
and that's what you're talking about
with the sunny what's it called sunny
school the school of sunny yes but
that's the thing that I know I could
post repost the video from a year ago of
me nearly chopped my head off through
there there which will get those views
that will make me sleep happy tonight
that's gonna make me no money but I'm
gonna invest in our instead of doing my
school to sunny which is gonna provide a
lot of quality education and may result
in two or three people signing up to the
Academy which is gonna make money you
know and for a lot of time for a long
time and it's something that I've
definitely started to realize and that's
what yeah can you still hear me yeah
yeah it's definitely something I've
realized over time that in order to
you have to start investing in you know
people to help you other staff members
invest in you know new technology new
software because use only so far you can
go nowadays on your own back and you've
only got so much time to do it and so
it's definitely something that over time
I've started thinking about doing yeah
yeah I mean that we do this business
principle series which we've started
doing recently and in that one of the
ones that we haven't got around to but
we'll probably take up a full episode on
is outsourcing areas that you are
weakened so I remember one of the first
big episodes I did was with Mike a shoe
guy that owns brute strength to times
cross for the Elliot Cup Games champion
- like in the team in like 2010 2011 and
I remember asking him about like how did
you grow his missus ons wack working
against gravity addi and then he owns
like brute strength it's like [ __ ]
hell how do you have two people that are
both CEOs it likes such like high-level
companies in the same industry and he
said that both of them just do the same
thing which is they know exactly where
their strengths and their weaknesses lie
and they employ people ruthlessly to
fill in where those weaknesses are yeah
well I've just I've just hired a
videographer but why is this for me when
it just come so when it worked comes to
working with people instead of just
paying someone a set fee give them skin
in the game give them a stake in in what
you're doing and it is far more
motivating for that person to work
harder to grow with you and to grow your
business especially when you're starting
out especially when you don't
necessarily have the cash flow to pay
someone a wage you know I've just taken
my videographer and because I've always
wanted to do YouTube and I found the
time to sit down and edit a video so
instead of saying like how much does it
cost put together a video I said look
you'll have 20% of all the revenue that
they make on YouTube there is a lot of
scale then for that person to put in
time and effort making that video great
and you know I think people then to tend
to take a lot more time into getting
something done well if you give them
that sort of incentive skin in the games
the perfect analogy for that so
I use that across most of my businesses
if not all of them good example video
guy Dean who everyone is watching will
know it'll be the guy that in this right
now yeah he takes it takes 50% of all of
the revenue that we make on YouTube I've
brought him on board with every project
I've just done we just did our first
brand collab with Reebok UK for the Nano
9 release we split that straight down
the middle I went and did a Christmas
seminar for communica which is one of
the UK's biggest broadcasting companies
they unsmooth the radio and Capital FM
and a few other bits and that again
brought Dean in on that and we keep on
going and you know now he's got things
he's incentivized to do that and on a
lot of people ask about the club promo
and how that ties in a good example of
this is when we go and run an event in a
nightclub there's two ways that we can
do things we can do a dry hire which is
it's 1,000 pounds an eye or 500 pounds
and I or 2,000 pounds a night whatever
it might be or we say you're on 20
percent of the door or 30 percent of the
door or however much percent at the door
and obviously if you have something
which is a percentage it protects you on
the bottom end because if you've got low
revenue which inevitably everyone has
everyone else a low revenue when they
first start a business right it means
that that person isn't this huge
liability which you've got to keep on
shelling out digging into your reserves
which then down the line mean that you
invest your money less effectively
moving forward but what it does for the
person who is being offered the deal is
yeah maybe they lose a little bit on the
bottom end but on the top end when the
business really starts shifting that's
when they get repaid so it's all well
and good everyone wins
it's a venue comes to us and says oh
well we want a thousand pounds a night
and we go okay well let's say that you
could take 20 percent at the door or
well you know in the mid depth of
December they might walk away with five
hundred quid but on Halloween they might
walk away with five grand so you like
well there you go yeah it's good man so
what's what's next you've got Ozzy
Samoas Ozzy Ozzy summer but Christmas
coming right yes that's it so for me I
spent so much to this year traveling I
still love doing my seminars you know
I've started doing retreats now as well
which definitely offer people a lot more
than just in
in there lifting I get to show people
the beauties of Bali in meeting new
people it definitely brings people out
of themselves and takes them out of
their comfort zones and having more of
an impact on people than just making
them better at lifting which you know is
very fulfilling for me and something
that I'm very much enjoying I still love
traveling and I still love doing my
seminars and that's getting popular and
popular again but moving forward this
year I'm not gonna be zigzagging the
planet doing seminars as much as I love
doing them I'm gonna be a little bit
smarter about the ones I'm doing and try
and just spend a little bit more time
here up now tilling till Christmas
get into a good routine get feeling good
about myself again get in shape get
six-pack for the summer get lifting
heavy I've got one trip to Saudi Arabia
to coach someone at their house and
private coaching session for a weekend
that's in the air that's exciting man
you know it's something new that someone
just reached out to me often to me that
so I'm gonna be doing that and you know
who knows what's gonna be coming next
but definitely for this for the near
near future it's just getting back into
my routine and yeah simple stuff brother
only in Saudi Arabia would someone have
the cash to be able to fly you from Oz
all the way over there oh my god Linda's
gonna have to make sure that you don't
come back is that part of an arranged
marriage or something like that I need
you can't even read I can't even do tape
then I've got to go to the embassy and
get all signed off and everything this
week that's but how exciting you know
and then I think January will start
traveling again gonna do some seminars
in the Middle East January and then I'm
just today sorted out seminars for
Toronto in Feb and then I've also got
another training retreat in Bali in
February so I'm up to February of next
year pretty much plans I'm trying to go
a little bit further ahead this time
normally yeah yeah just spinning the
plates all the time
Toronto in February absolutely freezing
that's what I've heard but I'm kind of
excited for that cuz it'll make a nice
change after the nice summer I'm here
and it means it might be I do some
skiing nice yeah that is good what about
you what you got on the cards bro so we
just had freshers we long freshers week
just out the way which is always a bit
of a brutal time of the year but we've
got we launched a brand new 1/2 million
pound super Club in Newcastle which is
great then we picked up a new Friday at
quite a prestigious Club which he's
taken over really nicely and then the
Thursday still solid so the club stuff
sticking over we're doing more brand
collabs which is like really cool and
different and kind of not a direction
that had seen the channel necessarily
going in but I really enjoy so Lucy and
the guys Reebok have been really good
are now officially tied in with Sauron
which is hilarious after like three
months of amazing people lie on this on
this podcast man some really like
interesting people which is cool that's
always what you talked about that's all
I want man I just want to have more
interesting conversation that's all
Rogan does right like Rogan does at
scale just what everyone would probably
want to spend their afternoon doing
anyway which is just sitting down having
a coffee and I'm gonna chat with some
guy that's crazy interesting ah that's
something I was going to mention this
earlier on when you were talking about
resilience and sort of continuing to go
past barriers the guide I spoke to you
last night his books down there guy
called Keith Cooper who wrote the
contact paradox so this guy has been
writing this book on and off for 10
years right he went through my three
dozen publishers and lost two agents in
the time it took him to write this book
so the books about the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence why we
should be concerned about Metis which is
outgoing sending messages as opposed to
receiving like it alerts us too
other civilizations which might be out
there and real like just coolest [ __ ]
big-picture thinking [ __ ] about what
would an alien civilization that's maybe
millions of billions of years advanced
what would they look like how would they
react to finding that we're in the in
the universe right and this guy's gone
through he's been sacked Bower dropped
by two agents he submitted the
manuscript to like three dozen
publishers and then he ends up getting
picked up by Bloomsbury who are the
people who ended up doing it and the
they'd already rejected it once like
five years previous but he goes back to
them and when you were talking about you
know if you have something which you
genuinely care about and you keep on
doing it and you feel and believe in it
enough it's so wishy-washy rikes you see
these quotes online these motivational
quotes like you know just keep grinding
is [ __ ] Gary Vee hustle and grind
like but increasingly I'm surrounded by
people who are living breathing examples
that that is an effective strategy and
this Keith Cooper guy he's talking to me
and he was a food the first podcast he's
done on the on the book and he finished
with this little segment he's not like
you know he's a [ __ ] astrophysicist
right like he's not an emotional dude
but he finished with this little segment
where he was like you know I've been
dropped by two agents three dozen
publishers and ended up getting picked
up by someone that rejected it the first
time if there's someone out there that's
got a project that they believe in I'm
just telling you that if you do keep on
grafting at it that you know it'll come
out the way that you want in the end and
that's exactly it man you know my life's
been consumed by this beautiful
wonderful weird sport of Olympic
weightlifting I've now managed to turn
into something that gives me a
livelihood and there's still something
I'm extremely passionate about in its
you know through all of that it's still
something that spits out some terrible
days for me some very dark time some bad
news it doesn't stop me continuing to
want to achieve my goals you know and
and give back to the sport give back to
the people that invested in this sport
and you know even for me now we're
looking at building a gym in Soweto in
February I'm gonna yeah so I'm gonna
South Africa this guy reached out to me
she came to my Senate of my training
retreat and said look there's this small
gym and sweater really deprived dairy
and South Africa and their training and
they sent me the photos of the
conditions and it was terrible they had
broken bars and they said they're doing
something great there and they're taking
the kids off the streets and get them
into lifting and I spoke this guy called
catty and he had his dream is to get
someone from Soweto to the Olympic Games
and I listened to his story in it just
resonated with me so much obviously with
with my childhood dream and you know I
thought I could do something to help
these people and I always like ride
straight back to that moment where you
know I needed the help and support to
get to the Olympic Games and Jeff gave
me that support and help that I needed
along with other people along the way
and you know I'm now in a position where
I've got an audience and I've got an
income and I want to help you know so
basically we're gonna be building a gym
in in Soweto and hopefully you know it's
going to be the first one of these
charities called lifting dreams the
charity and we're working with a few
different partners to raise money we got
our first fundraisers in a few weeks in
I'm doing like an open training session
in Sydney we also met a winemaker in
brass sir at one of my seminars a few
weeks ago so we're gonna put you be
producing my own wine and all the
proceeds from the wine is going to help
help build the floor at the gym and
Cerreto and we've got lots of crazy
ideas but that's fun too you know it's
it's that eventually will be what this
will be about when the Sonny Webster
Academy is making enough money for me to
live the life that one it'll be about
doing cool [ __ ] and helping helping
other people we're gonna achieve their
dreams may that's so cool like the
chance the opportunity to to help
underprivileged community like that's
sick and also the fact that you're
making your own wine like a
I have to say it doesn't surprise me
like and the nicest possible way it
doesn't surprise me well man it's been
an absolute pleasure having you one I
know that everyone will be assuming that
super happy hear from you again and we
don't we're not allowed to leave it this
long until the next one I need to get
you back on now of course not
well we'll have some more updates and
yeah it's been a pleasure thank you very
much I moved back on Chris and thank you
to everyone that's tuned back in to
listen to this and supporting Chris's
dreaming Chris's channel it's you know I
even find an extremely listen to listen
to so thank you Chris it's a pleasure
man thank you very much enjoy and I'll
see you the next time you back in the UK
take care brother
[Music]